Nostalgia, depression, and cinema's greatest
imaginary friend: It's time to take a journey
inside the mind of Riley Andersen.
Who knows?
You might even learn something about your
own mind.
Inside Out is centered around the hectic mind
of a child, and much of the plot involves
tackling the emotional disarray that characterizes
that period of life.
But the film also takes the time to hop into
the heads of the other people around Riley,
such as her parents.
When we get a glimpse into their Headquarters,
some interesting details are revealed about
the way maturity affects the mind.
In the minds of both Riley's mother and father,
the emotions operate as a much more cohesive
team, sitting together around a larger control
panel accessed by every emotion.
The emotions work in tandem, too, with each
one contributing a little to any given situation
— in sharp contrast to the incessant scramble
for control going on inside Riley's head.
Even the emotions themselves are shown to
be more level-headed in the adults' heads.
While their equivalents in Riley's mind are
shown to be driven by their respective emotions
most of the time, the emotions in her parents'
Headquarters are depicted more like professionals.
This doesn't mean that the adults aren't prone
to impulsive outbursts, but it does mean that
they've learned to manage those impulses over
time.
The question of which emotion is dominant
in Headquarters proves to be much more crucial
for a child, since only one emotion can operate
the controls at a time.
Indeed, it's Joy's autocratic central role
that eventually causes everything to fall
apart.
"You can't focus on what's going wrong, there's
always a way to turn things around — to
find the fun!"
In adults, meanwhile, it appears that there
is a "central" emotion at Headquarters — but
they're more of a team coordinator, making
sure everybody's actions are aligned.
It's never confirmed if the emotion sitting
at the center of an adult control panel is
constant or changes from moment to moment
as the situation dictates, but, whatever the
case, the emotions in charge of Riley's parents
are very revealing.
In her mother's mind, the leader is Sadness
— which makes perfect sense for an adult
who is currently experiencing a melancholy
life change, and constantly fretting over
her family's emotional wellbeing.
Sadness is, after all, the emotion that powers
empathy.
Riley's father, meanwhile, is having his emotions
coordinated by Anger, which is also a very
understandable adult response to the series
of setbacks and logistical issues he's having
to deal with at home and work.
Inside Out's message essentially states that
all emotions have their place in a person's
development, including sadness.
But a more seasoned viewer might also notice
that the film goes beyond that message, and
even enters more incisive thematic territory
in the way that it analyzes the role of Joy
in Riley's mind.
Joy is undeniably at fault for suppressing
Riley's more negative and nuanced emotions
in an attempt to keep her happy 100% of the
time.
But pay closer attention to the character's
actions and their consequences in the film
— specifically the way that Joy keeps desperately
replaying Riley's old happy memories when
she's reacting to the move to San Francisco.
Because it's difficult for Riley to find things
to be happy about in her new situation, her
mind keeps clinging to old, bygone sources
of joy.
But those memories can't do anything for Riley
in the present, except remind her that things
are not the way she wants.
By resorting to nostalgia, Riley makes it
harder to process her current situation, and,
in failing to process it, she loses any chance
of forming any new happy memories.
Arguably the most heartbreaking moment in
the movie comes when Sadness takes over Riley's
Headquarters just as she's returning home
to her parents, resulting in a long-overdue
emotional breakdown that finally allows them
to understand her pain.
The fact that Riley's control panel was turning
gray and inoperable before that moment has
been widely interpreted as a metaphor for
depression; she is only able to break out
of this when she accepts and surrenders to
the sadness her mind has been trying to suppress.
It's an incredibly potent insight — but
the film's depression metaphor runs even deeper
than that.
Essentially, Riley's depression is a result
of dysfunctional emotional processing.
Her mind cannot deal with all the feelings
that come with moving to San Francisco.
She may have been a very happy kid before,
but her happiness, her sense of self, and
her relationship with life were all contingent
on external circumstances that no longer exist.
Never before had she been cast so helplessly
into a situation that left her so vulnerable
to fear, rage, repulsion, and confusion.
As a result, she shuts down emotionally, because
her mind doesn't know what else to do.
"What have we done?"
It's only by accepting and moving through
the pain that she's able to break out of that
defensive apathy and feel again.
In the credits, we get an insight into the
Headquarters of other minor characters in
the film, and each one reveals something amusing
about the character in question.
Riley's school teacher, depicted in a bout
of frustrated boredom at her students' disinterest
in her class, is shown to be led by Joy.
This may seem odd at first, but it makes sense:
The ability to remain cheerful makes for an
indispensable tool in a middle school teacher's
arsenal.
The perpetually annoyed cashier at the pizza
place is managed by Disgust, which tracks
with her dry attitude towards her customers.
Since Disgust is the emotion of social and
aesthetic judgment, it's also no surprise
that someone who has to deal with customers
all day would default to being led by it.
The cool girl at Riley's school is, of course,
ruled by the constant Fear she has of being
exposed as a fraud.
We even get a glimpse into the real-life Jangles
the Clown, who, despite hating his job, is
ruled by Joy — a nice rhyme with the schoolteacher,
as they're both adults whose professional
lives revolve around keeping kids entertained
and engaged.
With Joy and Sadness lost somewhere in the
recesses of Riley's mind, it's up to Fear,
Disgust, and Anger to run Headquarters in
their absence.
At one point, Fear gives up trying to salvage
Riley's emotional state and attempts to quit,
leaving Headquarters through the same tube
that sucked up Joy and Sadness.
"Emotions can't quit, genius.
Bleugh!"
The emotions can't quit, but Joy and Sadness
were very much removed from Headquarters,
which was functionally identical to what Fear
tried to do.
This seems to suggest two things: The first
is that, while emotions can be accidentally
ejected from Headquarters, an emotion can't
voluntarily self-eject.
Our feelings might get messy for any number
of reasons, but we're not allowed to choose
which ones we get rid of.
The second is that Fear can't remove itself
from our minds out of, well, fear.
There's an argument to be made that fear is
the most primal of all human emotions — the
base instinct to evade danger and keep ourselves
alive and healthy.
We can block out our sadness, our anger, and
even our joy, but fear isn't something that
can be suppressed; it's always there to some
degree, an omnipresent participant in decision-making
processes.
Inside Out may be a kids' movie, but it's
also a Pixar movie, and, as such, it makes
at least a couple of adult-oriented jokes.
In this case, many of them revolve around
San Francisco.
The maddening traffic, the apathetic cashier
with a purple sidecut, and the broccoli pizza
are the obvious gags, but the funniest joke
is arguably the one that's most expressly
designed to go over kids' heads.
"What was that?
Was it a bear?"
"There are no bears in San Francisco."
"I saw a really hairy guy.
He looked like a bear."
To some extent, "a guy so hairy he looked
like a bear" is technically descriptive enough
to work as a joke even if you're unfamiliar
with a certain terminology.
But what's funny about the joke is the reference
to the San Francisco LGBTQ+ community, and
specifically to the concept of "bears" — which
is gay slang for plus-sized, hairy guys.
If you're an adult who's aware of the city's
status as a worldwide queer capital, the mere
suggestion that there are no bears in San
Francisco will be enough to get you giggling.
There are several references in Inside Out
that children would be very unlikely to get.
Heck, some of the references are esoteric
enough that even adult viewers might not pick
up on them at first.
The most memorable one is arguably the Chinatown
shout-out.
While two security guards are trying to solve
the case of the cloud man who was blown away
by Bing Bong, Joy dashes right through the
cloud man's wife as she's giving testimony.
"Was he with anyone?"
"Yes, and there she is!"
"Hey, come back here!"
"Forget it, Jake.
It's Cloudtown."
This, of course, is a hilariously over-the-top
nod to the bleak ending of the classic 1974
detective film.
"Forget it, Jake.
It's Chinatown."
At another point, when Joy, Sadness, and Bing
Bong are walking through the Dream Productions
lot, they pass a poster for a film titled
I'm Falling for a Very Long Time Into a Pit;
this is a clear parody of Saul Bass' iconic
poster for Vertigo — a 1958 film in which
James Stewart's character has a nightmare
about just that.
When a major character in a movie has a big,
tear-jerking death scene like that suffered
by Bing Bong in Inside Out, the story will
usually later take a moment to memorialize
or mourn that character in some way.
In this film, however, the characters never
acknowledge Bing Bong after he sacrifices
himself to help Joy to escape the Memory Dump.
When he's forgotten by Riley and fades away,
it seems like the movie forgets about him
as well.
This is a decision that may feel odd and unsatisfying,
especially for younger viewers, but adult
viewers will understand exactly why the movie
depicts Bing Bong's demise that way.
The very source of the melancholy underlying
Bing Bong as a character is the fact that
he's an anachronism, a relic of early childhood
with no place in an older mind.
He's a walking reminder that childhood ends
and never comes back — and once it's gone,
it's also largely forgotten.
All the ideas and imaginative adventures that
make up each child's own universe fade away
after a while.
They're not mourned, they're not eulogized,
they're not missed — they just go, and so
does Bing Bong.
A key plot point in the film is the fact that
Sadness is extremely knowledgeable about Riley's
mind; this is why Joy relies on her to guide
them through the vast realms outside Headquarters.
The groundwork for this is laid when Sadness
reveals that she has read almost all of the
"mind manuals," dozens of dense tomes detailing
the mind's workings and the way that memories
are processed and stored.
"Long term memory data selection via channel
subgrouping?"
"See?
Fun already!
You lucky dog, you're reading these cool things,
I gotta get back to work."
While this may appear to be a mere joke about
the fact that Sadness is left out of Headquarters
operations and ends up reading a lot to pass
the time, a closer reading reveals something
crucial about the film's themes.
Sadness isn't just key to fostering empathy
and understanding between people, it's also
key to self-understanding.
As adults know, sadness is the emotion most
likely to be conducive to self-analysis and
introspection.
Poets and philosophers alike have described
sadness as the emotion of the resilient, the
mark of those capable of facing the human
condition head-on.
No wonder Sadness knows the rules of Riley's
mind so well — she's the only one who has
bothered to have a look at them.
And, without Sadness, Joy could never have
found her way through Riley's mind.
At the end of Inside Out, it's implied that
Riley has attained the hard-earned gift of
emotional complexity.
She can now produce blended memories, and
her expanded control panel suggests that her
emotions will finally be able to start working
together.
But that's not the end of the movie's message
about the interplay between emotions.
It doesn't seem to be a coincidence that Joy
is the only emotion that features another
emotion's color in her design: deep blue,
in her hair and eyes.
She's also the only one who experiences another
emotion besides her own to a blatant degree.
If Riley's early childhood was spent clinging
to Joy to the detriment of other emotions,
Joy realizes that, as maturity comes knocking,
she'll have to start getting used to sadness.
The film's ultimate point appears to be that,
as a person grows up, there comes a point
when joy can only really exist insofar as
sadness does.
There's inherent loneliness and despair in
the human condition, a fear of loss and displacement
that follows us all through adulthood, but
there's also joy — and that joy comes as
a direct result of sadness.
Once we stop taking our lives for granted,
the good things become even more special and
beautiful, exactly because they're finite
and rare.
Joy learns this, Riley learns this, and Sadness
is right there to help guide them through
whatever comes next.
Heavy stuff for a kids' movie.